[Music]
all right well let's get started so this
is session 32 and we're now at the end
of year three of the worlds of
speculative fiction series and this time
we are looking at somebody who I was
supposed to do and then got sick so we
had to postpone him
Jean wolf who I really enjoyed rereading
I first started you know this book the
shadows the torture I got I think when I
was I remember right I was in high
school many of you probably remember you
used to be able to buy manobo set at the
drugstore and they were slowly
increasing in price at that time this
was this kind of a thick paper back at
that time and I thought it was you know
such a cool idea and then started
reading it and and really started
enjoying it but I can't say I fully
understood many of the words because he
uses so many Greek and Latin it words at
the time and then you know I read
through the rest of the stuff when I was
in high school and college and then put
it down and thought it would be
interesting to go back to there is a
good bit of world world building in this
and we'll talk about that in a bit and
he had he does have a very interesting
biography as well but I thought we could
start by looking at a few things that
some critics have had to say about wolf
and this series in particular so there's
this guy Baird Salas who wrote the book
of the New Sun these four books is too
complex of work to evaluate on one
reading it'll undoubtedly be considered
a landmark in the field one that perhaps
marks the turning point of science
fiction from content to style from
matter matter to manner mannered it
certainly is and stylish but under all
that glittering edifice of surprising
words and more surprising events of
character is there a story or concept of
any stature
that's kind of an open question Peter
Wright says that wolf is in effect doing
sort of sleight of hand with with
language says coming to understand the
book of the New Sun is like learning the
rules of a game if the reader succeeds
in perceiving the rules of his literary
game achieves the reconciliation plot
with story then the experience of
reading becomes an educational one and
he says that wolf is not preoccupied
with demonstrating how proficient he is
as a writer he's concealing his
slightest narratology chol sleight of
hand and constructing a puzzle so he
tries to alert the reader to the level
of perception required so these become a
difficult book some people have likened
this to you know science fiction's
Ulysses and I have to admit I you know
Ulysses was a book that everyone told me
I had to read I gave up on within a few
pages because I said I'm not going to
read this stuff other things do but that
I didn't do that with this he goes out
and he says the book of the New Sun does
not invite the reader to marvel at how
clever Woolf can be but it's a marvel at
his or her own intelligence in
perceiving one facet of the elaborate
textual game the author plays and so if
he's right that means that it's it's a
it's a series that allows you to be self
congratulatory in saying look how clever
I am in figuring out how clever this guy
is and you know I remember in in one of
my philosophy classes my mentor was
teaching Derry down Derry does somebody
plays with words a lot and and he we
were reading through one of his more
recent books and he said you know we it
was we went through this chapter and all
these allusions and he said you know as
I'm sitting in my study at home I
thought to myself as I finished up with
this chapter hell it's so great I can
figure out all these illusions and
Derrida is very clever in that he gets
you to get hooked in that way and then
you forget to ask you
is any of this true or is it all
[ __ ] you know
and so with philosophy right some of it
should be true with a novel it doesn't
have to be right so maybe there's
different rules the third person I
thought would be kind of interesting
Neil Gaiman has a very short essay on
how to read Jean wolf and he gives you
nine rules and I won't read all of them
but he says first trust the test the
text implicitly the answers are in there
and then he says don't trust the text
any further than you can throw it if
that farts Trixie and desperate stuff it
may go off in your hand at any time so
he's already contradicting himself from
one to the other and then he says reread
it's better the second time it's even
better the third time and anyway books
will subtly reshape themselves while
you're away from them
scrolling down ordinarily number reading
down a bit and see how influence we are
by technology he says there's two kinds
of clever writer the ones who point out
how clever they are and the ones who see
no need to point out how clever they are
Jean wolf is the second kind and the
intelligence is less important than the
tail he's not smart to make you feel
stupid he's smart to make you feel smart
as well same sort of line as the as what
Peter Wright was saying and then though
he concludes by just saying be willing
to learn which is kind of an interesting
thing to say about you know fantasy or
science fiction which is supposed to be
you know I mean what would you say
though the point of science fiction or
fantasy is it's it's to imagine things
differently but it's also to entertain
and to provide enjoyment to us not
necessarily to make us jump through a
whole bunch of hoops right what do you
find jumping through hoops enjoyable
yeah sometimes you have to jump through
hoops sometimes they want you to be
political sometimes they don't you yeah
but more other shoes so there's a lot
there science fiction is really more
like that than a lot of others yeah it's
interesting with wolf you know he
complains in one interview about people
creative writers writing stories that
are too political or too too moralistic
and he said that he said yeah he says in
that that they're creative writing
teachers reward that activity too much
which which might be you know the case
so to be speculative fiction you're
saying so the so would that mean that
some science fiction is not speculative
fiction okay
it's the Buck Rogers Cowboys in space
type stuff yes yeah yeah I mean that's
an interesting way to look at it because
usually this it's so speculative fiction
is the super Chandra and then you've got
you know fantasy science fiction horror
some subgenres like dying earth is
actually a John uhrin or alternate
history or things like that but what
you're saying is that sort of at the
core of speculative fiction better be
some speculative miss you know that
makes some sense so let's talk very
briefly well we can go into as much of
as you want but let's talk about his
biography he's a living writer he's not
that far from Harry's down in Peoria
still so you know I mentioned that to my
wife today anxious why don't you go
visit him and as a
well he probably has a lot of people
coming to to you know visit him that
probably be a lot of a bother
you know he's sure he's got fans who
have been you know asking him all sorts
of foolish questions for years and years
and years so I don't know that I would
do that
so he's born in Brooklyn and they fairly
quickly moved to New Jersey and then
they moved to Peoria and there he
actually meets the girl who I think
she's four at the time he will
eventually marry there they're playmates
and then in you know two years they
moved down to Houston Texas and his
father was a traveling salesman so he he
covered Texas Oklahoma and Louisiana so
we and that you know think about what it
must have been like back then you know
even now we're talking about a massive
territory that it would take quite a
while to drive around on roads where we
can drive you know 70 75 miles an hour
probably probably faster in Texas and
think about what it must have been like
it at the end time so 30 yeah 37 yeah
that certainly would have been so he you
know wolf was reflecting on his father
having a job during the Depression and
he said in one interview we traveled
from place to place wherever my father
could find work but I'll say this we
always had a place to live we always had
food he said one time he was talking
about this was Ben Bova another science
fiction author and but Volvo said well
we didn't Ben both his dad was a day
laborer and if he didn't get work than
the vulvas didn't eat whereas the wolf's
they they did all right he starts doing
some some you know writing he goes to
Texas A&M University he publishes one of
his first stories and this this the
commentator and then he drops out of
a.m. and he's drafted for the Korean War
he sees frontline action now in some
things he's listed as being a combat
engineer but he says that he was in the
infantry and and having been a combat
engineer myself I can see how you could
you could easily put those two together
because combat engineer squads are often
separated off from their company and
assigned to like a company of infantry
and when you're not doing engineering
stuff you're basically just doing
infantry stuff so you know it's it's
conceivable that he was he was doing
both and the war you know he said had a
big influence on him he said that when
you're in combat
it's very different than than being you
know behind the lines he actually used
the term bean-counter for that people
who would you know doing the supplies
and he said that um he was asked what he
learned from being at war and one of the
things he said was well you get to see
through all the lies that people tell
you about about what's what's going on
so you know that had some some influence
on him he then starts you know you get
he goes back and earns is his bachelor's
in mechanical engineering and he becomes
an industrial engineer for Procter &
Gamble he helped to develop a machine
that cooks the dough to make Pringles
potato chips so if you enjoy Pringles
wolf is partly responsible for that I
know my wife enjoys them quite a bit and
then he starts you know he starts doing
some some more writing and he eventually
quits his engineering job and takes this
job as an editor of a trigger plant
engineering and relocates to barrington
and while he's doing this this work is
an editor he also starts working on
these these novels and his process was
quite interesting he'd have you know
certain times the day where he'd get to
write and then he said that if he woke
up early provided it was before if it
was after 4:30 in the morning I guess he
must have some insomnia he would get
himself you know situated then just just
start writing so he found ways to make
the time work for him and you notice
that he starts you know winning some
awards he's got some books being
published and then the shadow of the
torture is coming out in in 1980 and and
he took his time working on those books
once those books caught on he decides
that he's going to become a full-time
writer those these books essentially
cement his reputation these are viewed
by many as his best work they've always
written a lot of other books as well and
you notice once he does become a
full-time writer is very productive
that's just you know book after book
after book after book some of those are
continuing the story found here many are
in in other areas and he doesn't you
know I doesn't do an awful lot of other
stuff he's not you know jumping around
the country or the world but he's you
know he's living his life his wife
eventually dies in 2013 and his vision
is apparently not that that great
anymore but you know he's he's you know
2015 a borrowed man came out so there
were a few other things that that were
coming up in interviews that I thought
were kind of interesting his reflections
on his own life or his religious
commitments and then about science
fiction and fantasy so I thought I would
read these to you he was asked by one
person
what is your faith stance and how does
it affect your writings and I don't know
what you mean by faith stance because
that's just kind of jargon and he said
I'm a Christian as a Christian I reject
belief and feint I believe in free will
and original sin I'm not a pacifist and
I don't believe it's wrong to dance or
take a drink and then first and follow
in another interview followed up and
said it's not too personal a question do
you consider yourself a professing
Catholic and he said yeah I go to Mass I
receive Communion I pray and they says
were you born a Catholic no I was a
convert and then the person so like
Chesterton he said yeah but it's a you
know it's a bad thing and that born
Catholics tend to look down on you but
being looked down upon has its
advantages and he said well like what
and he said well you don't put yourself
forward as an expert you understand
other people who are in similar
situations not just in religious matters
and so in his he is sort of very
matter-of-fact about this it's not like
you know Handa one you know sky opening
up you know religious conversion he's
decided he thought that you know sort of
like Alistair McIntyre's is still living
contemporary virtue ethicist who at one
time was a hardcore Marxist and then
made his transition to virtue ethics and
eventually became Catholic and if it
still teaches I believe at Notre Dame
although he may have retired from
teaching duties somebody asked him why
are you a Catholic a so well because I
think it's true and that's pretty much
yet you know and then somebody they're
trying to probe a little bit further
well you know do you do any special
things he said I go to Mass that's it
you know why do you go to Mass because I
want the Eucharist that is it's just
sort of very basic orientation towards
that the other thing that he talked
about was fantasy and science fiction
and in in one interview somebody said
your fantasy seems much truer to reality
truer to what we humans experience in
this life that most of what passes for a
realistic mainstream fiction and and I
really like this observation that he has
and you guys can say whether you think
this is true or not
he says fantasy is near the truth that's
all realistic fiction
typically about a married couple both
college teachers he's cheating on her
with a student so she cheats on him with
whoever's handy angst abounds how true
is that story for the bulk of mankind
realistic fiction leaves out far far too
much he says how old is a realistic
fiction and how old is fantasy and I
think he's he's probably right about
that I mean a realistic fiction is
realistic for the people who are there
in those situations but then the ones
who often become writing teachers and
there it tends to be this kind of in
writing communities this kind of you
know not what's the word it's not
claustrophobic cloistered right their
concerns are the concerns that they
think everybody has and everybody in
their little sphere does but then
there's a much wider sphere that that
could be talked about a little bit later
he said that he thinks that science
fiction maybe has an advantage over
fantasy he was asked why does science
fiction matter and he says I think it
matters because it's mind opening that's
it's great virtue ordinary ordinary
fantasy opens minds but not nearly as
much and so he talks about the Oz books
he says the Oz books may open somebody's
mind a little bit Alice and wonderland
is kind of mind opening but a lot of
science fiction is much more so he says
for instance I could write a story in
which a man is a conversation with his
gun I might do that sometime now you
know could could Lewis Carroll have done
that I think so
but he seemed to think that science
fiction has an advantage over fantasy
and I was curious to see what you guys
think about that does it in terms of
well in terms of speculation you know do
you think we can like arranged like a
hierarchy of genres in terms of which
can be most speculative
I'm wondering how he defines the terms
yeah if the talking gun is science
fiction enough and this is that that's
true yeah yeah of course there's another
context it's not just about time yes
it's just about what it says it's not
just about the talking guns yes because
there are thirty eyes right yeah that's
the point yeah Philip dick has a story
and I don't remember which one it is but
a guy can't get out of his apartment
because he has to pay his door to let
him out and he's run out of money yeah
and every single thing talks to him yeah
it's sort of like well the Internet of
Things yeah yeah I don't think I don't
think I actually want to live in a smart
house yeah so the the world that this is
set in and you know they there is I
think arguably genre sort of sub-genre
of dying earth stuff we talked about
Vance last time there's plenty of other
things like that this is similar to to
Vance's dying earth and you know wolf
actually I think if I remember right not
in these books but mentions him and in
some some interviews you've got a world
where mankind has gone out to the Stars
and there's still the possibility of
doing that but most people don't do that
and never dream of it and things of you
know sort of devolved to essentially
kind of a futile medieval sort of level
with with some advanced technology in it
and you've got this this Commonwealth
and then you say I gave you a math which
is not particularly detailed but
detailed enough and you can see you know
where severe ian is going and where the
threat from the north from Ostia is is
coming and apparently this is supposed
to be South America
yeah this is way more near future than I
realize the contents to look like
themselves yeah apparently there's been
some some you know reclamation of land
from the ocean and some some
modification of things and and so you
know you've got a very hierarchical
society where at the top you've got the
out arc the single ruler right the one
who essentially is a not even a
hereditary dictator because it's passed
on from person to person sort of like
for quite a while
rule was of the Roman Empire and below
him you have all these different strata
of people you have like a noble class
the excellence who you you know you have
to be born into that there's the petty
nobility the army Gers who or military
class you've got the Optoma tazed these
wealthy traders and then you've got all
the regular people then there's slaves
and you can fit in to any of these sorts
of things and the story of the main
character is is going to be you know
going from the bottom all the way to the
top by the end of the the fourth book
and there's all sorts of you know crazy
creatures again similar to advances
world right yeah yeah he's been seeing
in other ways too how so what do you
think about the language to write yeah
you know using lots of advanced advanced
words yeah and he doesn't always invent
words but they've met words but he does
a lot of it and but whereas wolf takes
his words from yeah he's appropriate
translation oh yeah those things in the
back actually he had no recourse to
invented terms he just reused yeah so
each fork concludes with a little you
know I mean the whole thing is supposed
to be a translation of something that
this guy found and so there's always
this appendix yeah so the second one has
like social relations in the
Commonwealth money measures and time you
know sort of explaining bits and pieces
and it's not like a complete
encyclopedia of this universe but he is
at least telling you something about
where where things fit in and and you
know we have wolf is very erudite so
he's using a lot of things from ancient
and medieval histories reappropriation
those words and then he does I guess he
does make up a few right like a cogent
you know but that's coming from cockles
meaning maybe years we had people you
know yeah so I had a few you know before
I say this before I talked about the
philosophical themes a little bit about
the world-building those of you who've
read this would you say that he actually
did world building and any like
systematic way or would you say it's
more to sort of he invents the parts
that he needs here and there to fit the
story I mean think about like Tolkien is
like the archetypal world builder you
know it creates languages
he has genealogies of people hold back
histories is wolf doing something like
that or is he more just kind of I don't
wanna say making it up as he goes along
but it sounds like you think it's making
it up as you go that's what it sounded
like you were saying I'm sure of how he
did it he might have plotted the whole
thing out ahead of time
yeah are you more sorry are you more
likely to run into like blonde issues if
you just kind of make sure about busy go
along well I don't think you just
totally just do stream-of-consciousness
right I think there is some some sort of
charting things out but I don't think
it's it's so elaborate as like what a
Tolkien or some other people have done
yeah and you would run into problems
because you got to keep track of all
this this stuff there's there's a couple
problems that would there's a little bit
off-topic but it's a really good topic
to think about there's a couple problems
that when writers are working on
something that has like grand scope they
run into you see this happen with TV
shows all the time and with with movies
where you start out and you've got a
really cool storyline with compelling
characters and you've sketched out like
you know like this much of the universe
and there's all this other stuff to
explore this is what happened with like
Stargate for example happened with
Babylon 5 you you so you've got some
stuff going on you've got a you know bad
guys that you have to discover how they
work and figure out how to defeat them
and then you do defeat them and now
you've expanded your your scope a bit
more you know a bit more of the universe
and you've got some responsibilities and
now you're in the expansion phase and
everything is really great at that time
the fans are like this is this is cool
stuff and the writers keep writing away
at it and then they start running out of
ideas and they start you know having
trouble figuring out how to it's almost
you know we often use this term deus ex
machina right you know the you just sort
of like but the bad guys are often that
in quite a few of these long narrative
stories because you just like make up
some terrible menace that how could we
possibly resist that you oftentimes
they're the ones who destroyed the
previous menace okay and then now if you
defeat them what's left you know it's
like going through them the next higher
and higher and higher sort of thing yeah
or like if you think about video games
right you have bosses and levels and
stuff like that and a certain point it
becomes so unbelievable that it becomes
kind of boring and I think a lot of
writers working for like sci-fi
television shows they there's something
about the the process they they they
they just don't think about well what
are we going to do three years from now
to keep telling this story and you can't
just keep telling the same story over
and over again there has to be some sort
of growth right I know the characters
are good you just keep saying how about
Starkey they kept telling the same
stories over well I like to keep coming
back yeah with Stargate they did they
they wound up having bigger and bigger
enemies and like these replicators yeah
oh yeah I forget who else they there was
some some other race that
no but they wound up sort of having been
yeah and then you know if you beat the
Replicators what that you know honey
there won't be a starts right at the
beginning telling you that in four books
from now you're gonna find out that I'm
the aunt arc yeah yeah it was going with
it I get the impression that he wrote
these as one book and had to break it
into four because like this does not
have a climax and it doesn't really have
an ending even the end book doesn't
really have that much of an ending I
would say you know yeah I think he was
working on these over a long period and
he he he said that you know he had the
luxury of being able to work on them and
not having to publish them right away so
he kept editing and editing and editing
yeah well beyond the science fiction too
though right now I'm thinking of where
there's a series I'm television show how
to commit murder or are you talking
about the dynamic of having okay now we
add another villain or now we add yeah
or twist and you can tell it's like okay
they're gonna add something now yeah you
can see it coming almost and then they
finish a storyline and then they've got
to create a new storyline because they
finish the storyline yeah I suppose
detective shows are probably subject to
that right especially if they're
character-driven new but new like
recurring enemies - you got him like a
nemesis of The Mentalist had that weird
epilogue season I never watched that a
character-driven interesting yeah I
always couldn't interested in when the
plotting just fails I love a bad plot
rather better yet no plot at all so I
enjoyed this my wife got into over the
last month or so watching the blacklist
which is actually kind of you know at
some point science fictiony watch it
because it's got James Spader and I like
him because a lot of the writing is
quite bad you know what this is enough
he was getting so ridiculous after like
three or four seasons that just knocking
off the characters they like this
this yeah what but boom so the point
that I was gonna make is that it seems
like they kept doing the same sort of
thing too and we watched up to you know
it's still an ongoing show so now we're
waiting to find out who the next
villainous you know they they have like
episode villains the people on the
blacklist but then there's these people
in the background you know the really
bad guys trying to do this or that you
know exactly yeah yeah yeah I must it's
hard for me to watch in part except for
that I like James Spader because it's so
far fetched yeah like you know it has
all of the terrible tropes of like the
hacker gets in there and just the types
of few Keys now they're they've gotten
into the the mainframe of you know
whatever place it is and that we were
joking that every single major character
gets abducted at least you know twice
during a season and that has to be
rescued it's very much like a series
like I'm just getting an aversion to
really ridiculous violence
yeah you know there's that there's
something to that I think there it's
it's very easy everything
lots of violence is just sort of easy
writing right and and you know I
remember watching and we're very far
topic with this but I remember watching
one of those Bond movies with Daniel
Craig Annette and after about 15 minutes
of watching I was like I can't watch
this anymore because the fight scene was
going on for about five minutes and I
was like Jesus just just one of you like
knock the other one down i I want to see
like some dialogue or some some plot or
gadget something you know something
happened because in science fiction you
see some of that both in the books and
in the movies you see some of that
gratuitous violence yeah this stuff but
in the movies you have to cool your eyes
and think about other things because
you're stuck in the theater yeah yeah
for this civilian in his church ring and
that was just a little bit room to what
I mean as part of their punishment I get
you get sentenced to either a lifetime
or six months of and then very precise
methods of no I mean but they were
talking about it in there yeah he also
said it wasn't going to bore you with it
well you didn't say it that way well
they talked about a few things
until you showed mercy and then they
kicked him out but but all those torture
work after that you know even after he
goes oh yeah then he becomes like an
executioner yeah yeah but I mean but
he's very clinical about it there's no
there's no remorse or anything like that
it's just his job and he sees it because
as part of the guild this is one thing
do they just inflict cute misery on
human beings and that's that's search
and just just the amount that they've
been detailed to do to because if they
go over you know they're if they were
sadistic about it then they wouldn't be
good at all scripted and they stopped
having women the torturers because they
were too I thought that was interesting
um but I also love that they call their
prisoners the clients yes yeah it's not
really a service you do I suppose as
when all those clients you can remind me
like kind of how like everybody use the
tortures that like within the universe
can remind me of like the history for
surgeons how they refuse like
historically is the way they were kind
of like nobody really wanted yeah not
like unclean but like that savory that's
for sure well you know there was the
working on cadavers which was already
viewed as morbid and you want to know
why somebody was cutting people open
like that and surgeon could say well so
I could save lives or something like
that
but I don't think a lot of people bought
it at the time
yeah quite true
still a problem in some parts of the
world today well so I had some
philosophical themes picked out that I
thought would be interesting to to bring
up I think one of the biggest ones is
personal identity you know you could say
the whole novel is about Sumerian
finding out who he is turns out that he
does find out like who his father
possibly is and then he also finds out
that he's the the person destined
the next aunt arc and it begins from you
know this very humble beginning as an
apprentice and so there's all of that in
what do you call that like a
bildungsroman or coming-of-age thing
going on
and that has to do with like figuring
out who you are but a lot of it is also
growing into who you are and then
another aspect is is also figuring out
who the hell are all these other people
you know for example the doctor Talos
and Bo Landers the the relationship
between them clearly doctor Talos is
kind of a or to come sketchy guy right
he's he's on the bank he's talking about
people who in earlier times were
considered disreputable he's a he's
putting on plays you know and actors
were in the Middle Ages were considered
quit disreputable and then Bo Landers
looks like he's actually his servant or
or something like that but it turns out
that's completely the opposite Talos
might we find that out I think in the
third book Talos is is actually working
for the Landers and blenders as though
the one who's calling the shots then you
also have a guy you know at first it
seems like she's somebody quite quite
nice and then it turns out she was
somebody quite terrible and but you know
not she's terrible in that she wants to
kill this Varian and trick him but you
know maybe she's not that big of a
threat but then suddenly she turns out
to be way more of a threat she's able to
recruit assassins
she's dogging him from place to place to
place there's also the character Dorcas
who has to figure out who she is
turns out she's dead has been brought
back to life when she didn't remember
anything yeah yeah but so wolf himself
says in the book of the new Sun I wanted
to show a man who was raised to do
terrible things and who reforms himself
from the inside and so I thought at the
guild of torturers and made the man a
torturer so that gives us some of the
character development arc but then he
complicates it I mean really early on by
having you know there's this possibility
of having other people inside of you
through this I forget the name of the
the the animal that when it consumes you
is alien animal yeah somehow I was kind
of but somehow yeah and you have them
sort of it's not just accessing their
memories you have them within you just
tell you what's very common there on my
third reading
ya know I looked more at the ones that
had interviews with him but yeah that
ought to do that you know in terms of
this coming-of-age yeah yeah you know it
kind of relates that they could he have
crisis of consciousness several times
you know he he really felt he had to put
the fact that he was killing people and
torturing them in the context of his
goal in order to do it because he did
have bad feelings about it
yeah I'm started with his first
girlfriend and in fact there's a lot of
teenage boy stuff in here he falls in
love with every except for except for
July 10 that's right it's just
so that's pretty good I think that's
good because they're all so heavy coming
from this guy who's the art that he's
telling you about his alleged memories
and he's just showing you it was a kid
yes I think it's interesting but not
saying I was a kid I fell in love with
her yeah it's hard to see how he he
wouldn't give him the way that she's
depicted how he wouldn't fall in love
with factly
yeah I wanted to say FEA but that that's
her sister yeah you know she's beautiful
she's she's exotic she's a damsel in
distress there's actually a line that I
there was a discussion that they had
that I wanted to bring it up because it
has to do with philosophy so he's
recalling this later on in Makua the
conciliator he says that 16 ortho so
that glow was attracted as I think young
women often are to these lectures on
Theogony theodicy and the like and I
recall one particularly in which a
failed the boy bound I guess it would be
pronounced put forward is the ultimate
truth the ancient sophistry of the
existence of the three a doughnut the
three Lords that of the city or the
people that of the poet's and that of
the philosophers her reasoning was that
since the beginning of human
consciousness there have been vast
numbers of persons in the three
categories so the regular people all
right the poet's the people who are
working with imagery and then
philosophers there have been vast
numbers of persons in the three
categories who have endeavoured to
pierce the secret of the divine if it
does not exist they should have
discovered that long before if it does
it's not possible that truth with a
capital T itself shouldn't mislead them
you have the beliefs of the populace the
insights of the Raps that'ss and the
theories of the meta physicians have so
far diverged that few of them can so
much as comprehend what the others say
and someone who knew nothing of any of
their ideas might very
well believe there's no connection at
all between them and then her her answer
to that is is this man not be she asked
that instead of traveling as has always
been supposed down three roads to the
same destination they're actually
traveling towards three different ones
after all when in common life we behold
three roads issuing from the same
crossing we don't all we don't assume
they all proceed towards the same goal I
found and find the suggestion as
rational as that it's repellent and it
represents for me all that monomaniacal
fabric of argument so tightly woven that
not even the tiniest objection or spark
of light can escape its nets in which
human minds become enmeshed whenever the
subject is one in which no appeal to
fact as possible so the very
metaphysical speculations and this is
variant saying this about about that
close stuff but you know she's sort of
like the total package she's she's you
know Noble she's beautiful she's
intellectually gifted how could he not
fall in love with somebody who can come
up with these sorts of interesting
insights into so this actually there's a
long history in philosophy itself when
it comes to religion of saying there's
three kinds of religions and they all
like point towards the same capital G
God but there are like three different
paths and Cicero talks about this in on
the nature of the gods he says well
there's the stuff for the ordinary
people and and that's mostly BS
you know sometimes it's a civil Civic
religion we call this right and you know
you got to keep all those rituals in
place because that keeps people
complacent and they've got their there's
Saturnalia to go to and and you know get
drunk and then forget about you know the
fact that we're running the show so
you've got that going on and that's not
philosophical at all that's you know
statues and temples and rituals and all
sorts of crazy stories about you know
Aries sleeping with Aphrodite and
getting caught up in a debt and all that
sort of thing
then you've got what the poets are doing
and the poet what they're doing is a
little bit more elevated and here you
still have stories right and you know it
could be you know ancient Greek poets or
it could be you know the Norse Etta's or
it could be you know all the sort of
stories that were generated within the
Christian world you know stories about
the Saints or things like that and
that's another path and then but it's
working with representations and so it's
always kind of money and then you get
the Philosopher's and they're the only
ones who actually are you know rigorous
and know what's going on and nobody
listens to them yes because this other
stuff is a lot you know more enjoyable
that to like sit and listen to some dry
metaphysician explain you know why
according to this argument God must have
these attributes but the Philosopher's
are on the right track and and so Cicero
represents it that way and you see this
coming up over and over again in history
so like I've arose in the Islamic world
we'll say something kind of similar
which is you know kind of dicey because
he's saying you've got like the ordinary
people you got the theologians who looks
like that that's dying you get the the
theologians and the theologians they
kind of know what they're doing but a
lot of it's it's actually just images
that they're working and then you got
the philosophers like me Alan Rose and
what I'm doing is the real stuff okay so
the philosophy I'm thinking about these
issues
the poet all the city the people in
truth representing in certain ways and
the other people are just enjoying it
yeah but what she's saying is instead of
thinking of it as three paths that are
all like going to the same spot right
mhm
think of it as why look at it that way
why not say they're doing totally
different things they're not even
talking the same language and so yeah
that's you know there's probably
something kind of attractive about that
another theme that I thought would be
interesting to talk about is and we've
already touched on this a bit is how do
we make sense out of this future culture
so we're we're given to believe that the
author is really somebody else severe
e'en and that somebody translated this
and that there are no exact
correspondence between the things that
are being talked about and the words
that that we have so then you know a
natural question to come up as well then
how the hell do we make sense out of any
of this right we have images I think in
our head from some of the words that he
is like Destrier right if we say the
word Destrier what do you think of a war
horse right doctors well dr. Seuss like
made-up words right he's taking words
that we don't usually use of their
actual words for the most part yeah or
they're derived from Greek and when like
I brought up that word kako gen which is
used for these aliens cacos means evil
or bad and then gen is you know like
group or a race right so the evil race
you can you know you can easily do that
with with
languages like Greek you can string
things together the same thing in German
you can do that quite easily in German
really say there are real words in there
he mentions the papal bull at one point
which is a Mayan sacred text like a
magic well one of the wives is one of
the magician's in that one of the wives
the names of one of the wives of one of
the characters okay he's referred to
yeah so you throwing them in there for
you yeah I mean he's got in these
appendices so he'll talk about different
different aspects like this one isn't a
note on provincial administration then
he attacks about archons tedtalks these
you know these are all its so these are
all words that were used in ancient
Greek we don't use them today anymore
the lictor the one who binds Clavin Jers
where the guards of the Vinc Allah the D
Marquis those who fight in two ways are
the uniformed police so he's um he's
using a language and it's supposed to be
a language that's translating a foreign
language that none of us know you know
and it has these words even if we can't
even if we don't know what they are
they're they're kind of evocative just
the way they sound I think you know
there's a lexicon of just is there
really yeah
that Monday and my little science
fiction book how big is it I don't know
I've never seen it I just heard the word
that it exists and and he's not gonna
read any werewolf until he gets that
books yeah again this is a little
off-topic but you know when you talk
about Philip dick every once in a while
people bring up the exegesis and the
exegesis is like this thick you know and
feel some way you can't understand dick
stories unless you read the exegesis
and you know you read the exegesis which
I would have done and a lot of it you
think some of this could have been
edited you know you could have could
have been shrunk down and it doesn't it
doesn't actually contribute that much to
many of the the stories but but a
lexicon would wonder if it tells you
what the original use within your
language points to it's not
world-building because he's using
existing languages existing geography so
it's not world building a sense of like
creating it's not in the sense of
creating a brand new world yeah I think
it's world well a lot of world building
seeks something from other worlds but
here you have it's a dying earth yeah
it's the world it's got its guts aliens
it's got space travel it's got
interdimensional travel it's got time
travel it's got now in there too
and it all fits into the story Tomita
that's a little building so i think i
saw old earth when i think of world
building i think of creating a whole new
world a whole new concept the only way
we can even like Tolkien was was using
templates right so he's
he's creating new languages but they
look kind of like you know the language
that he's teaching and his classes so
that if they were ran if they're so
radically different we wouldn't be able
to recognize them I think as as anything
you know so there always has to be some
some drawing on the familiar the
question is how much of it you can get
away with it all right yeah let's talk
about one of the other societies that
that's in there that I thought was kind
of a he you know he gets into this and
again he doesn't give you like the the
entirety of it but there the the ones
coming down from the north and fighting
with the Commonwealth II asked Ian's
there's a prisoner that he gets to meet
and they have a society it's very
regimented very it's a totalitarian
society essentially but it's
totalitarian beyond what most of our
totalitarian societies are able to do in
part because of the control of language
they have this this sort of authorized
texts and everything that they they say
is all part of what they call correct
thought everything has to come from
these texts sort of the with 1984 the
what the people in charge of trying to
do is reduce the vocabulary down to I
think they wanted 500 words was it it
doesn't even remember of him and then
they end quite gotten there yet with
this
it's instead of just a just a set of
words its phrases and the phrases can be
used to mean different things but they
only have a certain range of things that
they can mean so somebody laughs I mean
I don't have any examples of these but
somebody might say well do you want
porridge or meatloaf tonight
and then they would come out with one of
these phrases and somehow it would
translate it I want the meatloaf you
know and you'd get the meatloaf and you
only have those two options I mean do
you have like one hey I wrote down a few
of the phrases so here's one of them all
endeavors are conducted well or ill
precisely insofar as they conform to
correct thought so you might say that
like when you see somebody actually
doing something well or you might say
that when you see somebody doing
something badly right the same phrase
could be used for multiple things
whereas with brain with not breaking the
world with 1984 they're trying to reduce
through news speak things down to just
very rudimentary language because then
people wouldn't be able to think outside
of it so they're kind of parallel to
each other right oh the sapir-whorf
hypothesis they have the notion that
language the language that we have
conditions the reality that we can
perceive or think of they can perceive
more than they communicate that's a good
way to put it yeah usually the
sapir-whorf hypothesis is used to talk
about like how the languages are
constructed so you know I forget which
which of the guys was which I think it
was superior was really interested in
Native American languages and their ways
of depicting temporal and causal
relations between things which worked
differently than say English or the
other indo-european languages and so you
want to say that that those those tribes
using those languages could could
conceptualize time and space differently
than then we could no I don't I think
there's a problem with that insofar as
we can talk about them conceptualizing
it different we must have some
conception of what it is for them to to
be doing that right yeah
strict version of the science section I
just tend to like making it strict I
think yeah more like using magic words
but with magic words do you have some
sort of control over the thing right
because you know it's name yeah how is
that connected with the sapir-whorf
hypothesis with the science fiction
inter oh okay okay yeah so I mean it's
it's kind of an interesting society I
mean think about it would be like some
fight against a race of people like that
you know there's no compromising with
them to take them prisoner they just
babble at you and this weird language
talking to you about correct thought you
know there's there's a there's certainly
hints in there that they don't even have
exactly the same emotions that we do or
the the people of the story do you know
that they they they just there there
there's there isn't this capacity for
development that we have there there
society's very orderly ours is the
Commonwealth there is very haphazard
very yeah nothing goes as planned
it's always somebody bribing somebody or
subverting the rules in some way there
are rules for breaking the rules that's
a good way to put it yeah yeah and if
you break the rules the wrong way
biggest arguments for totalitarianism is
order yeah simplicity you know it's once
you have something like what they're
talking about is a skin Society though
you can no longer even make the argument
for why totalitarian society would be
better because you can't you can't think
of anything outside of that
non totalitarian society would just be
those I mean think about how they must
perceive others maybe even less because
savages at least have a certain kind of
structure order you know you could be an
ethnographer among them and maybe just
like insects or you know demons well
yeah it's the if you're an other you're
not human you're not like us yeah that
would be the big challenge right how do
you how do you observe them without them
killing it well there's a lot of science
you know and I mentioned Cicero and
nature of the gods and in that that
dialogue it's a dialogue between an
epicurean a stoic and a skeptic the
skeptic is actually a priest in the
Roman religion and he admits and Cicero
you know he you know went up through the
the system of offices they call that the
cursus honorum
and so one of that'd be connected with
the religious establishment he talks
about them laughing as they're carrying
out their augury because the common
people believe all this stuff and the
priests who are part of the elite are
like I can't believe we get away with
this book yeah yeah yeah so that was
actually one of the other things that I
thought would be kind of interesting to
talk about is you know social
organization of politics and how you can
never get away from it there's you know
there's the ought arc and then there's
all these sort of lower levels
and it's it's clear that somebody has to
be in charge because otherwise things
break down and the question is for for
what ends you know is the arc just
enjoying himself is he responsible for
everybody and you get different pictures
of that as it goes on and then you've
even got like a resistance movement this
guy vote Alice who so variance saves
early on and he gets connected up with
him you know you were talking about this
being a coming-of-age thing and like
falling in love as being part of that I
guess you know having a hero to look up
to who's kind of a rebel and then
getting connected with them and finding
out that they're not quite what they
they portray themselves or what you
thought they were I guess that's kind of
yeah kind of a theme there's a line in
there where one of the characters says
weak people believe was forced on them
strong people what they wish to believe
forcing that to be real what is the arc
but a man who believes themself want arc
and makes others believe by the strength
of it and you know if you think about a
conservative society like that there you
know there's been many of these you know
in our history most people they they get
the message about where they belong and
that's that's where they are and if
they're going to move up they move up in
certain determinant ways and and at the
same time there's always permeability to
to those who are willing to break the
rules and break them in ways that
somehow work out for them right so the
arc and what qualifies you to be arc
wanting to be ought are wanting to run
the show and the Guild's kind of you
know fit into this as well they're their
ways of organizing things but you notice
that you can you can they're not an
absolute you can break the guild rules
and not be killed even by the tour
he can be sent away with a nice sword
and a job like some darien is the other
thing that i thought would be kind of
interesting as a theme is talking about
the role that love plays in this you
know and i don't think that i don't know
you guys tell me if i'm wrong about this
i don't think there's anything like love
and the sort of expansive sense of like
love for everybody or christian charity
or something like that in these works
it's it's more particular it's like
erotic love for this person or that
person or it's friendship or it's you
know love for the comrade that you have
for for a certain time i don't see
anything going beyond that I don't think
the arc like loves the Commonwealth or
the people of the Commonwealth he feels
responsible for them but any defense up
but I know I wouldn't say he loves them
so very and his nature
it's a look back on his life yeah he's
focused on his own experiences not on
that broader picture of love for fellow
man or things like that yeah that's true
it's more of an individual love an
individual experience but he sees all
these other people and he he you know he
speculates about that man he has
judgments on them so presumably if any
of them were displaying that to a great
degree or talking about it he'd have
registered that wouldn't he
maybe but if the if if it's a look back
it's pretty centric to himself yeah yeah
but he's able to admit when he has
abstract love for things like the guild
because he isn't an attachment to that
history right a bit yeah
would you call that love how about
affection yeah that's great yeah he
likes some of those and tortures better
than others well that figures I guess
yeah big brothers yeah
Ria's like he's in a boarding school
essentially he just happened to be
learning some very different topics and
a different career track I suppose if
you're in a situation like that you
would you would get you know some strong
feelings about the people you're under I
mean I think back to like my high school
and middle school teachers and many of
them I can't remember at all then some
of them I really still dislike to this
day they're gone you know well I
remember some who I really liked to and
some who I really admired and and and I
there are a few were as I've aged and
this this has been the case too with
someone like my graduate school
professors as I've aged my evaluation of
them has choice so like there was there
was one professor who I only took a few
classes with him I didn't really like
him at the time but he actually was the
person who gave me the best advice when
I was a graduate student at the right
time and I recognized he was a pretty
wise guy much wiser than the people who
who I liked yeah
and so I mean if that I didn't like live
with these these people so I mean
imagine what it's like to like live in
the same Citadel or tower with people
like that have them control every aspect
of your existence it must be you know in
the military with yeah yeah purely
academic you know there are there are
some colleges yeah yeah although that
now they're well I mean you do have like
the ones that are training people for
they are colleges right so yeah there's
their whole focus is to get the boys
structured yeah obedient so military
military schools I mean if you had a
boarding school that was an academic one
and it was kind of far out where there's
really nothing else around there except
maybe cornfields or desert that would be
similar to that you know a lot of
smaller schools try to produce you know
one way for some smaller schools to try
to produce a distinctive experience is
to promote that that very close
connection I imagine like st. John's not
the military school but but the
the the college where they you know
there's very small classes it's focused
on close readings of texts not a lot of
professors I think that would be like
that it's about a private college where
they close read Greek a bit and summon
up the great gun pound and commit
murders no spoilers oh well and I think
about very conservative religious
schools yeah how about stimulators
seminaries yeah there is some very
conservative Christian religious small
schools where it's very in doctrinal
there people visited doctrine acient
yeah and I think with that to you and
say you leave school and you go home but
you're going home to a home that's
deeply informed by that and all of your
social contact service
those kids yeah because seminaries would
be like that you know I think about some
like the my mother's generation many of
the young men in that generation and my
family went to junior seminary and
almost all of them washed out only one
of them managed to go on and start
preparing for the priesthood and then he
met a woman you know and dropped out I
think it depends on the seminary
a friend who went to miserable seminary
and dropped out because it wasn't
rigorous enough you know it was more
mind-expanding
okay then her belief system when she
walked in so it was like she yeah some
of these things work just exactly the
way she'd been taught yeah yeah the
theology when she got into the broader
theology and the broader concepts it
burst her bubble that's that's a common
experience
when people have our very world it went
the other direction
yeah you often see people from very
conservative backgrounds swing you know
they they they've been told so much this
is only this way this is only this way
this is only this way then they find out
that there's like a whole range of
options you know like when they learn
search history and they see that there's
like discussions among very reputable
theologians about this this topic and
they didn't all believe the same thing
and then they they sort of swing to the
other extreme where they they're like
well this is all BS and they become
almost like fundamentalists of
secularism you know and it's that same
sort of complex of well there's only one
you know way that that this can be I've
seen that happen with quite a few
colleagues myself I've also seen quite a
few colleagues who go through some sort
of life crisis like they start out in a
very very conservative committed
Catholic you know the church's position
is right on everything and then suddenly
they want to get divorced and now
everything's kind of you know this is
all up to interpretation there's
goodness yeah there's a good bit of
there's a good bit of that I've seen as
well over the years yeah
and I've seen people do that with
political doctrines you know the Jesuits
are their own kind of thing
and their - the stall down to Milwaukee
to march to the father crowd anyway I
was only with my family that was sent
there because the tuition was you know
was boarding but I didn't have to worry
lived in the city yeah but the tuition
was higher than my college expenses yeah
yeah but anyway it wasn't what she was
it didn't unravel eyes her daughter
would you know I mean it didn't
straightener oh yeah I mean listen this
is the Mater worse this is sort of a
like a dirty look everywhere were way
off of Wolfe at this point this is a
sort of dirty little secret about
Catholic academia yeah yeah yeah and he
wouldn't have any problem with yeah so
you get all these schools where the the
parents you know they want to send their
kids to it because they're alumni and
they're like I'm gonna give my kid the
you know this or that experience that I
won't name any any any schools but
there's funny that I can sort of point
to and where that school is now today
you know 22 the third well 30 years
later usually is so radically different
and so there's so little Catholic
identity left in that school that the
parents are sending their kids to
something completely you know and odds
with with what they themselves thought
they were gonna get unless they do the
investigation and see you know a lot of
it has to do with like what does the
Corps look like you know I've seen a lot
of Catholic schools do core revisions
recently where the kids whether they
liked it or not what it would need to
take three theology classes three
philosophy classes three literature
three history and now it's like one of
each and that's that one's so generic
that you're not going to really learn
anything and then you know like one you
know one other thing in this basket over
here and and once you lose the core and
the reason you lose the course because
the stem majors say oh there's you're
making them take too many gen ed classes
you know and then you get other people
are like why does it have to be so
Catholic you know while it is st. such
and such
Oh or it is Catholic such-and-such yeah
who are more progressive yeah then then
the lady well you were there at the
right time to be sending me to talk to
priests because they questioned
everything I said this doesn't make any
sense this is oh yes and he was the
woman I was with you doesn't make any
sense because I really hyper-rational
yeah so that was just part of the way I
mean constructed so then they thought
this was gonna work if I didn't work but
yeah I drove a non-traditional Catholic
family or my grandfather would say yeah
the police puts his pants on one leg at
a time just like I do what does he know
I I did but I left the church
this is Wisconsin's yeah sure yeah yeah
so that's that's one of the key
questions of in all like the secondary
lid so I would say yes says he actually
get caught in a lie where where there's
a contradiction because the conjugations
people say they caught them so I looked
when I was reading it and I did I I
didn't get past this I read him before
yeah this time I got that through the
first two and I did I do remember him
saying he had plenty opportunities for
sex in the city at some point but all
along he'd been claiming his only sexual
relationship was with Thekla this is it
this was in in the first okay so it was
in there
well you know they asked question them
he said I could relate back to my many
experiences in the city and basically he
only went that one time to the
whorehouse yeah and any ethical ax and
so that's well later on he's gonna have
Dorcas well know by before that yeah
yeah of course a grandmother maybe just
experienced than he had well the
question then is does that make him
maybe yeah how much does it take to make
you unreliable
yes just lying about one thing certainly
trying to appear honest to the reader
lenka when alias shows up he stops
record scratches for a bit to talk about
you have to understand I thought she was
really hot and all of my dumb decisions
spread from this or is that to me that
sounded very reliable that's kind of
like the courtroom thing right where
you've got you've got somebody on the
stand and you say okay we've caught you
in a lie about this how can we trust
anything you're saying
right so the I guess the question that
is what does it take to be unreliable do
we have to catch him in several
contradictions well I was but I didn't
get to three and four and I'll just say
this that the people who are talking
about this we're on their second and
third readings yeah and they were really
looking for things and there's a lot in
there that you
think about one of the things I always
thought about wolf that was so
fascinating and I don't see it as much
of these are just some of us other books
is that things happen off off off camera
yeah and there's some reference to them
and it seems vague and you wonder what
and then a chapter later there's there's
a revelation but you're not sure that
was the time and you have to go back and
look and this happens a lot of wolf in
his other works not so much of these I I
remember reading one I just spent the
whole book doing it was one of the short
song and and it was such an incredible
look at the mi tears rolling down my it
was just an amazing work and I recommend
people read more wolf if you like this
because there's some of his stuff the
short stone I really liked the long Sun
I got bored with all the theology and
all the trade but ravings of priesthood
and thereby the fourth one or third one
I quit but the shortest one it's when
they're on a newer if they're on a new
planet and they're trying to make it on
this this is the new stuff this is the
old earth the new sighs it's the short
Sun there's three of them and they're
just fascinating I just just really like
them I have a few extra copies which if
I come from pool all bring them along
anybody can have a mental cool well you
can you can order that on the Amazon for
like about ten dollars or so yeah so
should we should we call this one to a
close and say thanks for great
discussion and we it's been a good year
again year three now we're moving into
year four of this worlds of speculative
fiction series
[Music]
you